salut ses chapeaux bottes mon grand père
qui est chanteur il m'a invité sur scène
pendant son concert et il m'a dit il m'a
présenté au public en disant c'est ma
petite fille c'est une grande chanteuse
elle va devenir une star plus tard extra
il m'a présenté comme ça au public et
c'est un moment fort parce que à cet âge
là moi je pensais pas que j'allais faire
de la musique vraiment mon métier et
puis plus tard je me suis vraiment c'est
dans enfin aujourd'hui c'est mon taf
quoi mon grand-père les parties et il ya
des moments où j'ai envie d'arrêter où
je me sens pas bien et nous c'est
compliqué et je me rends compte que ce
moment où j'arrive toujours à puiser de
la force dans ce moment là en fait parce
que si c'est bon lui croit en moi c'est
la personne king jeu qui arrive à me
faire sentir spéciale en fait lui il a
été chanteur il avec une des choses que
je peux être en train de vivre
aujourd'hui
mais il croit en moi et je me remémore
juste ce passage et ça me donne de la
force quoi donc pas abandonner pour par
lâcher pour continuer le deuxième moment
qui m'a marqué dans ma vie c est le
moment où voir m'appelle de nulle part
comme ça ils m'appellent pour me dire
pour me dire que les écouter un morceau
à moi et qu'il a envie que je figure sur
son prochain projet il nous demande en
featuring prince était c'était un peu
bizarre faut savoir qu'à cette période
là je faisais pas vraiment de la musique
j'avais enregistré un morceau un an
auparavant et c'est ce morceau là qu il
avait entendu
sam est vraiment tombé dessus de nulle
part quoi c'est sa marque un tournant de
ma vie parce que parce que je faisais
beaucoup de bêtises à cette période là
et je pense que j'avais pas bien finir
du coup après on s'est rencontrés gobain
à bruxelles et on a fait le morceau cru
là pour le projet autopsie 4 et
on a fait le clip qui m'a invité à bercy
je suis monté sur scène pour la première
fois à bercy dans le bruins vos boissons
en fait c'est une superstar et il me
fait monter donc ça veut dire moi
j'étais tellement pas conscience des
choses que j'ai même pas fait de répète
pas de balance rien j'étais arrivé comme
ça en fait soit leur genre de l'hôtel et
tous élus pété les plombs qui me va
est-ce que tu t'entraînes et
touche-t-elle anin tranquille tu vas
donc c'était vraiment à côté de la
plaque
et après quand même a dit c'est l'heure
de monter c'est que après ça après le
concert il m'a dit mais tu sais quoi
c'est un test non pour ses pattes à y
monter
c'est à dire ça comme ça mais pourquoi
jeter
ouais je suis monté ouais quand je
revois les vidéos non en plus j'étais en
j'avais quoi un beau 10 heures que
j'étais limite en culotte avec des bas
un bras levé j'étais en mode terra avec
une coupe escaliers et tout le troisième
moment c'est un moment important donc
après bon après le bercy et où j'ai une
période de travail sur la musique tout
ça et puis je suis reparti en fait dans
mais on dit qu aller de travers c'est un
travers je partis faire un peu mehmeti
mes bêtises et tout pour faire de
l'argent etc
et puis j'ai des amis qui ont commencé à
mourir des amics on commence à rentrer
en prison
je me suis retrouvé seul et je me suis
retrouvé à la rue et il me restait 60
euros et j'étais en fait je vais pas
m'en sortir
donc j'ai pris un bus pour londres parce
que les bus et deux heures trente euros
et au je suis et je suis arrivé à
londres avec 30 euros
en fait quand j'étais dans ce bus
j'étais trop mal parce que je me suis
dit en fait j'avais une opportunité
comme vale est venu et m'a tendu la main
pour faire quelque chose et et au final
belge et je passe à côté
et maintenant je me retrouve sans rien
en fait à devoir partir reprendre tout à
zéro donc je m'étais dit
quand j'étais dans ce but je me suis
fait un petit master plein je me suis
dit boy tu vas trouver un travail et tu
vas tu as fait et tu vas tout tout
chaque euro que tu vas voir tu va le
mettre dans ta musique
le mettre dans le studio jusqu'à ce que
tu retrouves ton chemin en fait et c'est
ce que j'ai fait donc je suis le soir
même où je suis arrivé à londres donc
j'avais pas d'endroit où dormir et où
j'ai trouver un taf le soir même dans un
bar j'ai commencé à travailler la
journée et le soir et à chaque fois que
j'avais un peu une petite somme d'argent
je descendais à paris sur enregistrer
jusqu'au moment où on me rappelle pour
l'enseignant maison de disques moi j'ai
grandi très vite j'étais confronté au
fait que l'argent le différencie
vraiment les gens tu vois pas ce que est
bref et j'ai grandi j'ai toujours voulu
faire de l'argent tôt pour rien au final
tu vois des fois on dit ouais mais ashby
grave parce que mes parents ils
n'avaient pas à oui mais c'est pas grave
tu peux aller à l'école même si tu
manges pas même si du coup on s'en fout
en fait termine t étude va prendre un
taf comme tout le monde mais c'est juste
des fois t'es juste pressé tu dis moi
aussi j'ai envie d'avoir ça j'ai envie
d'avoir ça tu commences les bêtises et
après ça devient addictif quand tu sais
que tu peux faire de l'argent entre
guillemets fascine c'est pas vraiment
facile mais juste des foires rapide
puisque tu as les couilles en fait de
faire les choses après c'est trop
addictif et je pense que ce qui s'est
passé c'est que la musique ça paraissait
long lent aussi sorti un morceau le
morceau le morceau de booba et il n'y
avait même pas été bien accueilli et
après le musée nan mais continue
t'inquiète tu verras ils vont comprendre
je suis là je rentre en studio de
rentrer en studio on donne et c'est bon
ça fait six mois à frère je fais pas de
biff je peux pas rester comme ça tu vois
je fais comment en fait et c'est juste
un souci bête que ça
et puis c'est quand la réalité le
rattrape et que tu vois les gens il
commença à mourir ils commencent à
rentrer en prison
et toi tu es là
en fait non en fait c'était de la merde
en fait ce que je faisais un événement
qui m'a remarqué fêter la sortie
d'antidote
et je dis pas ça pour faire la promo
parce que enfin petit moment où déjà je
peux l'interview j'ai pas besoin mais
d'un moment marquant et je pensais même
pas que ça allait me prendre autant le
jour de la sortie
mais c'est ça mon album qui a été
compliqué pour moi sortir je suis
quelqu'un de réservé j'ai du mal à me
livrer j'ai du mal à parler j'ai du mal
à sortir même deux de l'image dans
laquelle on m'enferme tu vois j'ai
tendance à en boire comme la jolie fille
bête
donc je vais me présenter comme un jeune
fille bête parce que c'est tout c'est
comme ça et je sais pas j'ai du mal à
être moi etc
je ne savais pas comment montrer autre
chose de moi parce que je suis réservé
vous n'aurez pas à parler je n'arrive
pas trop à m'exprimer
donc je fais juste ma musique comme elle
est